OWN, HE TOLD A REPORTER TODAY AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> TONIGHT HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
TRYING TO PUT THE FINISHING
TOUCHES ON A PLAN FOR
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
AFTER BEING BLINDSIDED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP EARLIER IN THE
DAY.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL IS IN
WASHINGTON TO TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED, AND MAY BE WHAT'S
NEXT.
>> A CHAOTIC DAY AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEARLY SPIKED A
CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED IMMIGRATION
WARM COMPROMISE.
>> WHAT DOES THE BILL HAVE TO
HAVE?
>> I NEED A BILL THAT THIS
COUNTRY BORDER SECURITY.
AND A SENIOR WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIAL LATER CLARIFIED SAYING
THE PRESIDENT MISSPOKE ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION.
AND CATCH AND RELEASE AND THE
VISA LOTTERY SYSTEM.
AND IT WOULD ALLOW THE SO-CALLED
DREAMERS TO APPLY FOR A SIX YEAR
RENEWABLE BESIDES.
>> I THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD
BILL, VERY GOOD COMPROMISE.
AND THIS CAN MAKE A LAW.
>> HOUSE G.O.P. LEADERSHIP HAS
BEEN PLANNING VOTES NEXT WEEK
AND A MORE CONSERVATIVE PLAN
FROM JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN, BOB
GOODLATTE.
THEY SEEM TO ENJOY THAT CHAOS.
>> YOU MEAN THE PRESIDENT
COMPLICATED THE SITUATION WITH A
COMMENT?
I JUST DON'T FIND THIS SHOCKING.
>> THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN ON
CAMERA CONTINUING THE WAR OF
WORLDS.
>> I HATE THE CHILDREN BEING
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATS LAW AND WE
CAN CHANGE IT TONIGHT, WE COULD
CHANGE IT RIGHT NOW.
>>